parmi les vaccins anti qu'ovide le sérum
américain moderna la haute autorité de
santé le des conseils pour les moins de
30 ans l'instant s'appuie sur une étude
selon laquelle il accroît très
légèrement le risque d'inflammation du
coeur chez les jeunes méritent khalifa
principaux aux remèdes aux maux de cette
pandémie les vaccins et rennes messager
ne sont pas pour autant sans risque
chose que l'on savait déjà grâce aux
rapports de pharmacovigilance
c'est désormais confirmé par épi phare
et puis phare est une structure
française qui associe l'assurance
maladie et l'agencé nationale du
médicament dans un rapport de 27 pages
le groupement scientifique affirme qu'il
existe des risques d'inflammation du
coeur suite à une vaccination father au
mode à cette étude confirme l'existence
d'un risque de millau cardy tout
péricardite dans les 7 jours suivant une
vaccination contre la copie de 19 avec
un vaccin arn messagers chez les
personnes âgées de 12 à 50 ans
particulièrement les jeunes de moins de
30 ans ce risque est plus élevé avec le
vaccin moderne à l'aube d'une possible
troisième dose obligatoire l'inquiétude
est permise n'est pas de quoi à céder à
la panique non plus et puis farc tempère
car ces risques sont très faibles la
haute autorité de santé évoquant le site
de très rares cas de myocardite le
bénéfice de la vaccination dans sa
globalité ne semble donc pas être
remises en plus alors sur quoi s'appuie
ce rapport concrètement c'est une étude
cas témoin a porté sur des personnes
âgées de 12 à 50 ans hospitalisé en
france pour une myocardite ou une
péricardite soit 919 cas de myocardite
et 917 k de péricardite ces cas ont été
groupés avec 9190 témoin pour la
myocardite et 9170 témoin pour la
péricardite de même âge même sexe et
même lieu de résidence les conclusions
montrent que la vaccination avec moderna
serait à l'origine de 132 cas de
myocardite supplémentaires par millions
de doses administrées chez les jeunes
est de 18 cas supplémentaires de
péricardite pour le même nombre de doses
injectées quand on met en balance
l'efficacité des vaccins contre les
formes graves du coc vide 19 et ses
risques existants mais peu fréquents et
à l'évolution favorable
le rapport bénéfice risque des vaccins
n'est pas remise en cause même si ce
bilan demeure positif la myocardite peut
avoir des conséquences non négligeables
sur la santé cette maladie touche le
mieux car le principal muscle cardiaque
les symptômes sont assez douloureux
comme le rapporte cette mère d'un
adolescent de 16 ans deux jours après la
première injection du vaccin moderna le
jeune homme ressent des douleurs assez
intense au niveau du coeur il disait que
c'était comme si on lui praille et le
coeur il a été pris de douleurs à la
maison il était plié ce attrapé la
poitrine il était décomposée aux
urgences de pasteur il a été hospitalisé
ils l'ont gardé s'il n'avait pas été
hospitalisé on ne sait pas ce qui se
serait passé il avait une inflammation
cardiaque due aux vaccins c'est écrit
noir sur blanc il a un traitement
pendant trois mois et est interdit de
sport pendant un mois quand c'est mal
soignée on risque un avc ou une crise
cardiaque un cas isolé évidemment est à
relativiser puisque aucun décès n'a été
rapporté parmi les personnes
hospitalisées pour ces infections
contractées à la suite de leur
vaccination dans ce contexte elle la
haute autorité de santé déconseille le
recours au vaccin moderna pour les moins
de 30 ans et recommande dès lors qu'il
est disponible le recours au vaccin
kaiser dont les risques de myocardite
sont 1 5 fois moindre selon épiphane des
recommandations pour le moins tardive
qui peuvent tout de même alerté sur les
dangers réels des vaccins arn messagers
risque d'un point de vue strictement
scientifique voire politique ils sont
pour l'instant les seuls garants ou
presque du contrôle de l'épidémie